this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies there's a lot of hype over
grand unified theories and theories of
everything but no one ever seems to be
asking the following question why are we
even trying to unify everything to
answer this we need to take a look at
the original unified theory the
inverse-square law yes I'm aware that
many of you may have heard of it before
but but barely anyone ever explains why
it's such a big deal so why is it such a
big deal it's a pattern that appears
over and over again and it all started
in 1604 - the timeline there was a guy
by the name of Johannes Kepler who you
probably know for his laws of planetary
motion which he published in 1609 in
1619 but in 1604 he was proposing rules
for light what he called the optical
part of astronomy those were simpler
times in science reading his actual
words can be a bit confusing these days
because well you know people talk
differently back then but but here's the
basic idea say you've got a spherical
source of light maybe a light bulb
Kepler's interest was the Sun which is
also a spherical source of light but
we're gonna use a light bulb instead say
you turn the ball bond and then
immediately off again you've created a
spherical shell of light that spreads
out equally in all directions
now that shell only has so much energy
in it as the shell grows that energy has
to spread thinner and thinner and
thinner which makes the light dimmer and
dimmer and dimmer it's actually pretty
relevant for studio lighting which is
why half the videos that come up when
you search inverse square law are
lighting tutorials anyway Kepler used
the idea of this spherical shell to come
up with a rule for how much light dims
as it moves outward since the light was
spread over the area of the shell and
that area is 4 PI R squared the
brightness of the light should drop off
like 1 over R squared the inverse square
of the distance that's why it's called
an inverse square law if you double the
distance you quadruple the area if you
triple the distance
yunano pull the area and so on the
bigger the area the dimmer the light so
we
clip those multiples over but this isn't
just limited to light it works for sound
too and frankly anything we can imagine
spreading out uniformly you might call
it a unified theory of spherical flows
didn't you say this was supposed to be
profound or something
yes yes and it's so much more than this
back to the time line several decades
later around 1665 Isaac Newton was
studying motion and thought up another
inverse square law this one for gravity
it actually explained Kepler's laws of
planetary motion from the beginning of
that century it's called Newton's law of
gravity it should really be called the
Newton's hook law of gravity but history
can be cruel and lazy sometimes anyway
notice the square in the bottom the
square of distance just like before does
that mean gravity flows away from a
source nope it does nothing of the kind
then why is it an inverse square law
exactly in Newtonian mechanics gravity
is a force yes we now know it's
space-time curvature but don't get added
me at the time line Newton's force of
gravity is described by this law in
inverse square law if you double the
distance between the earth and say a
satellite you divide the force between
them by 2 squared or 4 if you triple the
distance you divide the force by 3
squared or 9 and so on almost as if
there are spherical shells involved I
imagine this seemed pretty odd at the
time then again maybe they didn't think
about it that deeply at least not for
another century in 1784 charli's Coulomb
came up with another inverse square law
this one was for electric charges and we
now call it Coulomb's law actually he
was French so his name is pronounced
that stopped right there I clearly can't
even print out German names I'm not even
gonna try French okay I would like to
try coulombs force law looks like this
it's another inverse square law they
just keep appearing I mean look at how
similar these two laws are it constant
out front a property of two different
objects on top and the distance between
those objects squared in the bottom it's
almost like there's some fundamental
reason almost like you could unify them
into a single law but that law wouldn't
come until we see Carl Fred
cows in 1835 who gave us what we now
call Gauss's law keep in mind though
Gauss was a mathematician and we all
know what they do they generalize things
yes he wrote up his law using an
abstract vector field a field is a value
or set of values assigned to every point
in space so a vector field is just a
vector assigned to every point in space
a vector being a value and a direction
remember when we thought the inverse
square patter was a unified theory of
spherical flows well in 1835 Gauss
realized it was actually a pattern of
three dimensional fields as long as that
field has a spherical shape what we call
spherical symmetry then Gauss's law
spits out an inverse square which is a
big deal
light moving away from a bulb inverse
square law sound moving away from a
speaker inverse square law even some
spherical flows obey inverse square laws
in this case the vector is velocity
because it's about motion but velocity
isn't the only vector that exists the
gravitational field around the earth is
also a vector field it might not be the
flow of anything but it's still a vector
field and it has spherical symmetry that
means you get in inverse square law the
same goes for the electric field around
a charge it's not the flow of anything
but it's still a vector field with
spherical symmetry that means you get an
inverse square law but this poses a
limitation Gauss's law tells us they're
not really inverse square laws they're
inverse area laws that R squared is
really a 4 PI R squared these two laws
should really be written with a 4 PI R
squared at the bottom we just clump the
4 pi together with the constant in front
for simplicity both of these laws
require there be spherical symmetry if
your fluid flow isn't spherical
there's no 1 4 square law if instead of
a charge we had a charged rod the
symmetries are no longer spherical which
means no more inverse square it's
approximately an inverse square from a
great distance but not in the details so
as it turns out while inverse square
laws are a profoundly common patterns
they're not quite as profound as we
hoped venting and stop physicists from
trying to unify things anyway in 1885
Oliver Heaviside unified electricity and
magnetism by pretty much inventing
vector calculus but then in 1915
Einstein ruined unification by replacing
Newton's law of gravity with general
relativity it had to be done but it's
unfortunate so why was the inverse
square law such a big deal it's a big
deal historically because it hinted that
everything was connected physicists got
a taste and they just can't let it go
maybe we'll unify everything in the near
future maybe we won't
maybe relativistic gravity is so
fundamentally unique it can't be unified
with anything one thing is for sure
though Newtonian gravity and electricity
are incredibly similar so similar that
it's convenient to use gravity as an
analogy for electricity which is exactly
what we're gonna do in some upcoming
videos so do you think we'll find a
theory of everything someday please
discuss your opinion in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
by far the most common comment from the
last video was how to grab a Towns
escape a black hole one graviton models
never work hence the struggle too even
if they found a model that did work it
would still have to be consistent with
everything we know about black holes
nothing escapes a black hole anyway
thanks for watching